Hi everybody.
I can't really see
you, but hello.
My name is Krispy.
I am a developer
advocate for Google.
I work in probably one
of the coolest roles
I think Google has.
And that is, I am a
games developer advocate.
I play video games, and I'm
paid to play video games.
But not only that, I
get to help our partners
build their video
games and release them.
Basically, my role as--
it's an engineering role.
It's to help our third party
game partners integrate Google
technology into what they do.
So why am I here?
What am I going to
talk about today?
Well, I am going to talk about
game development and Android
TV, something that I'm actually
very, very passionate about.
I'm going to talk about
the constraints involved
and give my thoughts on how this
is a boom for game developers
who are interested in making
an impact on the evolving era
of new TV.
I will also endeavor
to give you exposure
to some helpful code that should
allow you to jump in quickly
and experiment.
You're all game
experts, I'm assuming.
And it's my hope that
by the end of this talk,
you'll be able to do what
you do already even better.
And perhaps a good
place to start with this
is maybe a discussion about
where video games first met TV.
You know, the Nintendo
Entertainment System, right?
You might be inclined to
think that the NES was
groundbreaking.
And it was.
I'm not discounting that.
It came out in 1987.
And it was a phenomenal success.
I mean, we still
talk about it today.
I don't know if you
saw my belt buckle.
Right?
This has influenced my career.
So why is this important?
Because it was influential.
But we actually have to go
back in time a little bit
and look at the
Magnavox Odyssey.
1972.
All right?
This is cited as the first
video game console for the home.
And the Odyssey was initially
built with discrete components.
This was before a deal
with Texas Instruments
that led to more condensed
multi-chip design.
Now, one side note here is that
National Semiconductor proposed
a single chip design to go into
the Magnavox back in 1975--
the first SOC, they
were proposing.
But due to the existing
deal that Magnavox
had with Texas Instruments,
the Odyssey 100 and 200
ended up shipping with
Texas Instruments multi-chip
solutions.
But in 1976, the
Odyssey 300 came out.
Now, this version was one of the
first game or TV game systems
that included a
single chip design.
It was the first one, but
it was one of the first.
The owner of the first
SOC in a video game system
goes to the Coleco Telstar,
which used the same chip
as the Odyssey 300.
And this chip was produced
by General Instruments,
and it was the AY-5-8500 chip.
I mean, I'm not going to
go into the specs of that.
You can look that
up on the tubes.
But the thing that's
amazing about this
is General Instruments--
now defunct, by the way,
they don't exist
anymore-- was based
in Pennsylvania and
specialized in semiconductor
and cable television
equipment manufacture.
So what we have
here is a case where
TV is influencing video games,
which is influencing TV, which
is influencing video games.
And they're sort of
ratcheting it up.
All right.
So I need to pause
here, or else this
is really going to turn
into like a history
lesson on video games.
And that would be awesome,
but it's really not what
I'm here to talk about today.
So if you're interested
in this kind of thing,
there's a great book I
would personally recommend
to you called "Console Wars."
Use your favorite search engine.
Find a retailer.
Pick it up.
It's a great read.
And I felt that you
would appreciate stuff
like this, this level of
detail, given that you're
interested in game development.
Let's go back a little
farther in time.
Let's shift gears a bit
and talk about old TV sets.
For instance, did you know that
the first electromagnetic, or
electromechanical,
television was demoed here
in San Francisco on
September 7, 1927?
That's pretty cool.
We're in the same city this
stuff was first demoed in.
Now, these TVs obviously
were very primitive.
But we're looking at
it from the future.
At the time, this
was groundbreaking.
This was revolutionary.
And also, the fact that we're
evaluating it as primitive
kind of makes sense, given
the available technology
of the time.
Certainly video
games couldn't exist
without the developments that
took place in early TV sets
like this.
And the thing I want
to highlight here
is that the industry
evolution of TV hardware
is actually markedly different
than that which took place
in the computer industry.
Simply put, the
TV hardware space
did not evolve as
quickly as the computer
industry did because of the
use cases that were involved.
TV is markedly
different in a use case
than a computer or a console.
So if we just look at this
quickly on a spectrum timeline,
we can see electromechanical
TVs hit retail shelves in 1928
to 1934.
That's when they
were really popular.
And that technology evolved into
purely electronic televisions--
yeah, they had transistors
through vacuum tubes
and stuff-- in the mid 40s.
And then we have the fast
forward like 25 years,
almost 30 years, to
the Magnavox Odyssey
before we see this next step
in evolution of interactivity
with television.
I mean, what you are
doing in these early days
was like turning a
knob and maybe getting
one or two channels.
But the evolution proceeded.
I didn't include
the modern stuff.
I'm assuming all of you are more
familiar with things that took
place in the 90s and so on.
I've mentioned use
cases a number of times.
Let's dive in there
just a little bit.
Let's look at, say, a console
use case here on the left.
With a video game console,
what are you doing?
You've got maybe a
16 button controller.
And you're pressing
those buttons probably
pretty rapidly.
And you're
internalizing, as a user,
what's going on on the
screen in front of you.
And you're building
a mental model,
and you're reacting
very quickly.
And you're pushing more buttons.
And there's this cycle,
this repeated cycle,
that goes very, very quickly.
And you're leaned forward
when you're engaged with this.
You're thinking.
You're active.
You're involved
directly in the action
that's happening on the screen.
Now if we contrast
that with what's
going on when
you're chilling out,
you're leaned back
on your couch.
You have your 40
button remote control.
I don't know why they have
40 buttons-- honestly,
too many buttons.
But they're also
super high latency.
How many of you have experienced
the frustration of pressing
a button, and you're
not quite sure
if the TV really picked it up?
Low latency.
You're not going to be
making a lot of decisions
very quickly with the TV.
Usually it's, I want
to turn the volume up.
I want to turn the volume down.
I want to select
something to watch.
And that's pretty much it.
These are very different
use cases, right?
So why is this important?
Why am I talking about this?
And actually, you know what?
I haven't even talked
about phones yet.
Phones need to enter
this discussion, I think.
Now again, I don't
have time to go
into the whole history of
phones with the telegraph
and where all this came in.
So I'm going to
just basically say
the mobile game market is huge.
All right?
I feel I don't need to
make the case for this.
It's self-evident.
And given the successes
that have happened
in the mobile space with
their evolution of technology,
and engagement, and market
success for a lot of the game
development companies, the
question naturally arises.
Hey, can this be applied to TV?
Can this whole model
work in the TV space?
I think it can personally,
but with a caveat.
And the caveat being, we need
to set the right expectations
for both the development
communities and the consumer
communities in order for
this to be successful.
I feel that currently
a lot of expectations
that come from other platforms,
and other devices that you're
regularly using, both to
watch media and play games,
are affecting what
your expectations are
in the TV space.
So I want to talk
about a constraint,
or what constraints are here.
I'll give you a second
to internalize that.
So I'm going to state clearly
that Android TV is not trying
to be a games console system.
It's not a games
console platform,
just like Android is not
a games console platform.
But there are games
that run very well
on both of these types of form
factors, the mobile and the TV
space.
I feel game
developers need to be
mindful and self-aware about
targeting features that
are specific to certain devices
when those features are maybe
not compatible with a
broader set of devices
within an Android
or mobile ecosystem.
For example,
building a game that
only works with a specific
type of controller,
or uses a specific hardware
feature on a specific device,
means that you're adding
your own constraints
to your development process
when you shouldn't be.
Don't pass on your
constraints to your users.
I'm going to transition
here into something
slightly different.
Let's look at the spectrum of
current Android TV hardware
and what exists out there,
because I don't feel this
gets enough service when we're
talking about this space.
There are really three
classifications of hardware
that we should
consider, especially
when developing games.
There are operator boxes
that we see here on the left.
These are lower
performance GPUs, CPUs.
An operator box is
typically made and given
to subscribers of a
cable operator's service.
They are meant to
deliver the service
value that is being promised
by the service provider.
There is an incentive
for the service provider
to produce something
that is cost
effective for their business.
Ergo, you're not going to
get high performance chips
inside an operator box, OK?
The refresh cycle for these
is completely dependent
on the service operator and
can typically range anywhere
from 2 to 10 years.
It depends.
You can get a lot of longevity
out of some of these boxes.
And they're optimized
for video playback.
Now if you look at the
middle here, integrated TVs.
Integrated TVs are
televisions that are smart.
And they have an
operating system.
In the case of Android TVs,
I think the most prolific one
right now is the Sony
Bravia line, which
includes Android TV in it.
These are great.
I love these things.
They're huge.
The color's great.
The experience is wonderful.
They fit right in the middle
when it comes to performance.
This doesn't mean
they're under-powered,
but it also means
they're not overpowered.
You're not going to be able
to have 100 different shaders
operating on your
multi-dimensional BSD
trees of tons of models
being rendered in real time,
and adaptive physics with
physics-based rendering on top
of that.
No.
You're going to be able
to get a good gaming
experience like you would
on a mid to low range phone
or tablet.
That's the kind of performance
you can expect on that.
OTT boxes, over the
top boxes-- which are
different than operator boxes.
Over the top boxes are more
console-esque in nature,
in that they are hardware
that a consumer typically buys
on their own and adds
to the TV in order
to extend its functionality
in some manner.
So I've just put the example
here of the NVIDIA Tegra.
That's the SHIELD TV.
This thing's a beast.
It's got a lot of
performance characteristics.
It's really powerful,
and it's definitely
targeted towards gamers.
I'll talk more about
that in a minute.
Let me just go back to the
TVs, the integrated TVs.
I didn't mention the
refresh cycle here.
TVs are typically
refreshed, and this
is sort of a global
average, anywhere
between six and nine
years-- every six and nine
years, typically.
And there's not a lot of
refresh cycle generations
in the modern TV sense.
But you can expect the
user will upgrade their TV
system every six to nine years.
Different than a phone, which
is every one to two years.
Over the top boxes, this kind
of fits in the middle ground.
It could be anywhere from
two, to four, to six years,
depending on the features
that it's offering
and how quickly those change.
So yeah, this is
really important
to consider as a game developer.
Because you should be
positioning yourself
right in the middle for
the broad distribution
that I think everybody wants
when they release a game.
Let me just talk about the
SHIELD TV for a moment.
I think the hardware that
NVIDIA's created is great.
I'm a gamer.
I've got every game
console under the sun.
And I really enjoy
playing with this.
I've got a few of these at home.
And while this is great at
playing AAA content with a game
controller, I'm
not sure that you
want to tie yourself necessarily
to one specific vendor.
The whole case that
I'm trying to make here
is you need to consider
constraints in the broader
sense of game design to allow
yourself to reach the biggest
audience that you can.
I'll let you read
this for a second.
The larger market will be
with integrated screens,
such as what I showed you
a couple of slides ago.
This middle market
flavor of Android TV
is the one that I'm
encouraging you to explore.
In order for your
game to be available
to all potential users in
the mid-range and above,
the constraints are
a bit more strict.
The SOCs, systems on a
chip, in the mid-range TVs
were simply not
designed for AAA games.
They were designed to create
great media experiences
and game experiences
at a price point
the middle market
consumers can accept.
The blending of use cases
can be a little disorienting
to game developers
who are coming
at this from a different
experience model.
Typically, you're
targeting a console.
You are targeting
a computer spec.
TV is a different space.
There's a theme here.
Now, if we talk about
porting for a second,
porting games from the mobile
market into the TV market.
This makes a lot of sense
because, well, there's
a whole plethora of
libraries out there.
There's code base there.
There's a lot of
successful games
that would make a lot
of sense running on TV.
However-- however,
however, however-- I've
seen this happen too many
times when I review games.
I will get a submission, and the
simplest things throw me off.
How many of you have
touch screen TVs?
Or even if you did--
don't answer that.
Even if you had
touchscreen TVs, would you
want to get up from where
you're sitting on your couch,
walk the 10 feet, and
mash your greasy palm
on that beautiful,
slick glass screen?
Probably not.
OK?
So make sure that
the games you're
making embrace the
constraints of the TV
and that they reflect
it in the user model
that you're presenting.
Now just to cap this off, I
want to talk about two games.
These aren't TV
games, necessarily.
Well, "Badland" actually
is on Android TV,
but I'm calling these out
for a different reason.
"Candy Crush," I'm sure you're
familiar with the name "Candy
Crush," if you have
not played it yourself.
"Candy Crush" is amazing.
And it's amazing to me
for one simple fact.
They embraced a constraint of
swipe and totally owned it.
They made an experience that is
phenomenal on mobile devices,
because all you
have to do is swipe.
Everything else was
sort of not focused on.
It was the swipe experience
and optimizing it
for the most enjoyment.
That was their constraint.
In the case of
"Badland," what did
they do that stood
out in my mind?
They made a game that works
amazingly well with one button.
You can do a single tap or
you can do a single click.
That's why it works
on TV with a remote.
And they totally owned the
experience around that.
It's not overly complicated,
but it is highly engaging.
And the important thing is
both of these games are played
by people who are not gamers.
They don't
self-identify as gamers.
What they do is they
enjoy an experience.
And again, this goes
back to why I'm talking
about the middle market.
All right.
In the interest of
time I must move on.
But now we're going
to talk about some
of the technical bits.
These aren't so much
constraints as pieces of advice
that I hope to imbue
upon you to help you
along your journey
in developing games
that either target
TV first, or help you
in porting your games
from the mobile space.
So let's talk about
one that I think
came up in the
last presentation,
but I'm going to beat
on this point again.
It has to do with this.
Remember we talked about TVs
not having touch screens?
Yeah.
If you have a game that's,
say, in the Play store
that needs a touch screen
when you're on mobile,
but you're going to
adapt it to work on TV.
What do you do so it
doesn't get filtered?
You do this.
You set uses feature for Android
hardware touchscreen required
equals false.
Now, why am I actually spending
more than just a sentence
on this?
Well there's one
important thing here.
Android developers
haven't had to worry
about this particular
uses feature before.
Why?
Because all Android applications
implicitly assume touchscreen
exists and is required.
So if you're going to build
for TV and support mobile,
you need this.
This is the most
important thing.
Don't forget this.
While we're at it, here's
a couple other things
that TVs don't have that you
probably want to feature out.
I don't know about you, but I
don't have a camera on my TV.
And I don't think I
want one in my TV.
So yeah, if you're integrating
middleware packages
like some sort of ad library
or what have you, some of those
require camera.
Remember to set its uses
feature required false,
or you're going to filter
yourself off of TV.
I had a partner recently
run into this problem.
They'd released the game,
Then they added an advertising
package that required camera.
And then they
couldn't figure out
why their game wasn't
showing up anymore.
So just quickly analyzing the
manifest revealed, hey guys,
you've got a camera requirement.
TVs don't have cameras.
Location.
GPS.
Unless someone is actively
stealing your television,
chances are it's
not going to move.
So you probably want
to remove, or at least
set the required
equals false for GPS.
Microphones, I get a question
about microphones occasionally.
Microphones exist in the remote
control, some remote controls.
But believe it or not,
the remote control
is not part of your Android TV.
It is an accessory.
And so the device
itself does not
have a remote control, or
at least current generation
devices don't have
a remote control.
I don't know what the
future's going to bring.
But again, going back
to that middle market,
you want to reach as
many TVs as possible.
It's a good idea to set
required equals false on this.
NFC.
I don't know.
Again, why would you walk
up to your TV with something
and touch it?
Maybe there's a use case
there I haven't thought of.
But again, you're
going to want to set
required equals false for
NFC, and obviously telephony.
Yeah, my TV doesn't
do phone calls.
And I'm glad for that.
And then touchscreen obviously
I talked about already.
Now-- pardon me.
Now that we've turned off
all these required features,
what if I have code that
uses these features?
What do I do now?
Am I totally boned?
Like, ugh!
No, no.
You just use a
little bit of code.
Now, I'm showing you
Android code here,
but this could be adapted
for other languages.
Unity has facilities to
call into the Android stack
and do these exact
things as well.
So you want to get
the package manager.
You want to ask the
package manager, hey,
do you have this feature
that I think I want
to use in this particular case?
And you can branch from there.
You can decide, hey, I'm
going to use this or I'm not.
In this case, this example
that I'm showing you,
we're actually doing sort
of a branch logic here.
Hey, does it have
a touch screen?
And if it has a touch screen,
does it have telephony?
Then there's a good
chance this is a phone.
If it has the touchscreen
but not telephony,
there's a good chance
that it's a tablet.
Well, what about the other
case where it doesn't even
have a touchscreen?
Does that mean it's a TV?
No.
It just means that it
doesn't have a touch screen.
Uh-oh.
Now what do we do?
Well, what if you need to detect
if you're running on an Android
TV or a mobile device?
What is a reliable
way of doing this?
The thing that we
recommend is actually
going to the UI mode
manager and querying it
for what UI mode
it's currently in,
because Android TVs operate in
what's called lean back mode.
You know, when
you're leaned back
and you've got your
remote control,
and you're just chilling
watching Netflix.
So, yeah, again, very
easy, light code that you
can apply to your game logic.
You might want to take
a picture of this.
This is important.
With this check combined
with the other checks
around using features,
you can quickly
determine what the
capabilities are of the device
that you're
currently running on.
This could be important for a
multitude of reasons, inputs,
or decisions about
what you're going
to do with the UI,
how constrained it is.
One side note here, this is
really useful for determining
if you want to add
sort of a-- wow,
my brain's drawing a blank.
There's a border you
want to put around
things to prevent overscan
from affecting your game UI.
Because developing
for phone, you've
got pixel perfect screens.
You can push pixels right up
to the edges and it's fine.
But on TVs, not all TVs
are created equal because
of this thing called overscan.
Again, I don't have a lot
of time to go into it.
But it can eat up to 5%
around your entire border
of your display space and
you have no control over it.
So the best thing to do is
detect if you're running on TV.
Either give the user the option
to adjust or scale the display
area accordingly,
or if you don't
want to provide that, you
don't want to build it in,
just assume a 5%
margin for yourself.
And put all the important
information more
towards the center.
While I'm on the topic of
things we should do with TV UIs,
we should probably talk
about network state.
This is more of a personal
gripe that I have around
what I see in a lot of games
that I download on mobile.
Games that require network
access and then only
check for Wi-Fi make
me really angry,
because I have very
high speed cell data
plans that I could perfectly, or
I could for sure take advantage
of.
But the games that prevent me
from actually using it really
bother me.
On TV it's a different story.
You might have
Ethernet or Wi-Fi.
So now we've got this crossover
spectrum of, it could be 3G.
It could be Wi-Fi.
It could be Ethernet.
What do we do now?
You should really
just be checking, hey,
am I connected to the internet?
Do I have network access?
This is the way to do it.
Don't go after Wi-Fi.
I mean, I'm not saying
don't ever check Wi-Fi.
I'm saying for the
general connectivity
to the broader world of the
internet, you should just do,
am I connected?
And then if you want
certain features to only
be available in Wi-Fi, then
you can do a Wi-Fi check.
Remember to always add the
user's permission, entry
permission, access network
state when doing this, or this
won't work.
You need to put that bottom
part in your manifest.
So what if you need
to check for Ethernet?
That's actually not that much
more code at all, actually.
You can just, again, get
the active network info
and check it against
type Ethernet
in the connectivity
manager constant.
I'll give you a second to
take a picture or scribble
anything because we're
going to shift gears again.
I'm good at that, right?
Shifting gears?
No.
Let's go back to the
infrared remotes.
TV remotes have been around
for a long, long time.
I think the first
ones were actually
wired right into the TVs.
And I believe, if memory
serves me, it was 1954.
And NEC TV was
introduced in the US that
had a long cable
with a channel up
and channel down
that actually had
a mechanical actuator
on the channel knob,
and it would turn it to
the different channels.
We've progressed a
long way from then.
Most of the remotes
that you get now
actually have an 8-bit
microcontroller in them
to deal with the codes
and do the IR blasts.
But infrared remotes
are a reality
for today's TV environment.
And you have to consider
that as a game developer.
Maybe you want to have a game
that operates as a strategy
game, something
that's less twitchy,
that could take advantage of
being played with a simple IR
remote.
If you can do that, you're going
to be compatible with almost
everything.
So consider this an
optional design constraint,
that if you can pull it off,
you could be very successful
with people, again, who are
not labeling themselves gamers.
All right?
I'm going to quickly go
through these last parts,
because I'm running
short on time.
Likewise, maybe you want
to step it up a notch
and consider just
regular remotes that
come with Android TV.
So you've got either Wi-Fi
direct or Bluetooth-connected
remote controls.
Or maybe you want to go to
the 16 button game controller.
As we're stepping
up here though,
we're cutting off chunks
of our potential audience.
So just keep that in mind.
I'm going to close out here, the
last technical piece before I
bid you adieu.
The game controllers that I
mentioned on the end there,
you'd think this would work.
Right, if you wanted to specify
that your game requires a game
controller, this
makes sense, yeah?
And it uses feature
Android hardware Gamepad.
It follows the pattern
of everything else.
Except you'd be wrong.
This does not do what
you would assume it does.
And I'm about to
break your brain.
So we were talking before about
accessories and microphones
and stuff.
And so I got this
Android TV here.
And I got my paired Bluetooth
16 button controller.
And the reality
is the controller
doesn't exist as far as Android
as a platform is concerned.
So what you actually need
to do-- and I realized
I'm missing the
slide for this now.
Silly me.
You actually need to specify
that if your game requires
a Gamepad, you have to put uses
feature Android name, Android
hardware Gamepad,
required equals false.
So if you require a
Gamepad, the requirement
has to be set to false.
Does that make any sense?
It's something that I want
you really just to remember.
The reason for this has to
do with a lot of legacy stuff
that went on with the way
the permissions system works
and the filters work.
But I want to
convey it on to you.
Please, if you're going to
build a game for Android TV that
requires a Gamepad,
set uses feature,
Android hardware Gamepad,
required equals false.
Just remember that.
Because at the end
the day, it all
comes down to the
experience that you're
going to provide to those
in front of the screen.
All right?
Couple of resources
here for you.
We've got a great site
on building TV games.
Highly encourage you
to check this out.
It's got a lot of
information that
is valuable beyond
what I've talked about.
And given that I've given
you a few history lessons,
that stuff is not on this site.
I did a Medium post
maybe six months ago
just on how to detect
Android TV and Unity.
That might be useful to you.
And lastly, we have
an amazing site
that's been put together
with a lot of hard work
from our developer
advocacy group
on making games with
Google technology
that I'd love for you
to check out and see
if there are things in
there that your games
can benefit from.
So I'm going to do
questions offline.
But thank you very
much for your time,
and I hope you
enjoyed this talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]